-Attorney General William Barr
testified in Congress today
after news broke
that Special Counsel
Robert Mueller
complained to Barr about his
description of Mueller's report.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Let's just remember the public
waited almost two years
for Robert Mueller's
final report.
If you tuned into the news, it's
basically all you heard about.
Everyone wanted to see it.
This thing
was more highly anticipated
than the last Avengers movie,
and almost as long.
[ Laughter ]
I hope -- I hope my burn doesn't
affect your box office.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone wanted answers to some
basic questions.
What happened in 2016?
What was Trump's involvement?
And what did he do after
the fact
to interfere in
the investigation?
But when the report
was finally delivered,
the first we heard about it
wasn't from Mueller himself,
but from William Barr, Trump's
hand-picked Attorney General.
Barr sent that infamous
4-page letter
summarizing Mueller's
448-page report,
which right off the bat
is impossible.
You can't boil a report
that long down to four pages,
and you shouldn't try.
That's like saying
the Battle of Winterfell
was about a dude who smoked
too much weed
and thought he was a bird.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't want to make this
all about Bran,
but, Bran, buddy,
what are your powers
and when are you going to use
them to be helpful?
[ Laughter ]
You're like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bran...
I know you can hear me, Bran.
You're like Superman
using his x-ray vision
to heat up a Hot Pocket.
[ Laughter ]
Do you hear me, Bran?
Bran. Bran!
Don't do that eye thing!
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Ugh!
[ Music stops ]
I don't know why I bother
with this guy.
Barr's initial letter basically
said there was no collusion
and that Trump was not guilty
of obstructing justice.
And it was a very successful
PR campaign
because it shaped the initial
media coverage
of Mueller's report before
we actually got to see it.
And on top of that,
it allowed Trump to claim
over and over again
that he had been exonerated.
-It was a complete
and total exoneration.
The Mueller report was great.
It could not have been better.
The result was great.
No obstruction. No collusion.
No anything.
Total exoneration.
Complete vindication.
Everybody waited for
the Mueller report,
then it turns out
that there's no obstruction.
No collusion. No anything.
I won. No collusion.
No obstruction. I won.
The finding was very,
very strong.
No collusion. No obstruction.
No Russia. No nothing.
-Trump went so over the top,
he literally claimed
there was no Russia.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
The report was very strong.
Mueller said there was
no obstruction, no collusion,
and the country of Russia,
it doesn't even exist.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
Trump went so far in celebrating
after Barr's letter
that he claimed
Democrats were on life support.
-After three years of lies
and smears and slander,
the Russia hoax is finally dead.
The collusion delusion is over.
And they're on artificial
respirators right now.
[ Laughter ]
They're getting mouth to mouth
resuscitation.
-They need mouth to mouth?
[ Laughter ]
Every time you do a rally,
you look like a guy who got
locked inside a sauna overnight.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But despite Trump's celebrating,
we now know Barr's initial
letter and press conference
summarizing Mueller's report
were lies.
First of all, Barr left out
all the evidence
Mueller gathered about
obstruction of justice
and on top of that, he left out
key parts of sentences
that he quoted from
Mueller's report.
Here's CNN explaining
one glaring example of that.
-Mr. Barr cherry-picked
this line.
-Investigation did not establish
that members of the Trump
campaign conspired
or coordinated with
the Russian government
in its election interference
activities.
-The context is key.
Mr. Barr ignored the first half
of the line.
The investigation also
identified numerous links
between the Russian government
and the Trump campaign.
And this line, "The campaign
expected it would benefit
electorally from information
stolen and released
through Russian efforts."
-You can't leave out
part of a sentence like that.
That's a huge difference.
That's the difference
between telling a bartender
who takes your keys,
"I've had four beers,
six shots of whiskey,
four line of cocaine,
ten margaritas,
but I'm good to drive" and...
"I'm good to drive."
[ Laughter ]
So we already knew Barr's
initial letter was misleading.
And now we know we're not
the only ones who thought that,
because another person
who complained about it
was Robert Mueller himself.
-We've got breaking news
at this hour
that one of the chief criticisms
of Attorney General William
Barr's summary
of the Mueller report
was made by none other than
the Special Counsel himself,
Robert Mueller.
-Justice Department officials
familiar with the issue
tell NBC News that three days
after Barr released his summary
of Mueller's findings,
the Special Counsel
in a letter reviewed
by "the Washington Post"
said Barr's descriptions did not
fully capture the context,
nature, and substance
of Mueller's 448 page report.
-Wait. So you're telling me
Donald Trump was lying
when he said this?
-No collusion, no obstruction.
No Russia. No nothing.
Damn it!
But I already took Russia
out of my map!
[ Laughter ]
Also, also...
[ Applause ]
...just as a general rule,
you never want to get a letter
from Robert Mueller.
You don't even want to get
a look from Robert Mueller.
If I bumped into someone
on the street and I looked up
and saw that face,
I would need...
-Mouth to mouth resuscitation.
-So now we know that even
Mueller himself
complained that Barr's letter
was misleading,
which is shocking, because
Barr was specifically asked
in a previous congressional
hearing if he knew
how Mueller felt about
his letter
summarizing Mueller's findings.
And Barr told members
of Congress he had no idea.
-Reports have emerged recently,
General,
that members of
the Special Counsel's team
are frustrated at some level
with the limited information
included in
your March 24th letter,
that it does not adequately
or accurately, necessarily,
portray the report's findings.
Do you know what they're
referencing with that?
-No, I don't.
-Did Bob Mueller support
your conclusion?
-I don't know whether Bob
Mueller
supported my conclusion.
-Yeah, you did.
There was a letter.
And there's no way you just
forgot about
a letter from Robert Mueller.
That's like forgetting about
a note on your windshield
that says, "I know
what you did last summer."
[ Laughter ]
So now we know that the guy
who spent almost two years
putting together
a 448 page report
about a criminal conspiracy to
interfere in the 2016 election
complained that Trump's
hand-picked Attorney General
misled the country
about that report.
That's huge news.
And yet, when they had
the chance to ask Barr
about that news
in a hearing today,
Republican Senators mostly acted
like it didn't happen.
Like Senator Lindsey Graham.
Now remember, this guy
is the chairman
of the Senate
Judiciary Committee
and he's holding a hearing
with the Attorney General
of the United States about
the Mueller report.
So you'd expect
that he'd at least read
the whole thing. Right?
-Here's the Mueller report.
You can read it for yourself.
It's about
400-and-something pages.
Can't say I've read it all,
but I've read most of it.
-What do you mean,
you haven't read it?
That was the assignment!
[ Laughter ]
Are you the guy who shows up
to book club, and says,
[ As Graham ] "I'm real excited
to talk about 'Moby Dick,'
but if we could just avoid
any details
about what happens to the whale,
that would be great.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't get to any
of the whale parts."
[ Normal voice ]
I know it's long,
but senators should read
the whole report.
It's possible.
I mean, Elizabeth Warren did it.
-I was on an airplane yesterday,
and started reading it.
Read it way into the night
last night.
And I got to the end.
-I'm impressed that she read
a 400-page legal document
on an airplane.
And now you know if you sit
next to Elizabeth Warren
on a night flight, she gonna
have her light on.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, now time to get some sleep.
Oh, no, Elizabeth Warren!
[ Laughter ]
So Graham admitted he hadn't
even read the whole report.
And then he decided to spend
the rest of his time
harping not on Mueller, but on
the GOP's favorite obsession,
Hillary Clinton.
Specifically he went back
and read old unearthed texts
from FBI agents
involved in the Hillary Clinton
e-mail investigation
to claim that they were
bias against Trump.
-This is what Strzok said
on February 12th, 2016.
Now he's in charge of the
Clinton e-mail investigation.
Oh he's -- Trump's -- abysmal.
I keep hoping the charade
will end
and people will just dump him.
February 12th, 2016.
Page is
the Department of Justice lawyer
assigned to this case.
March 3rd, 2016.
God, Trump is a loathsome
human being.
Strzok -- Oh, my God.
Trump's an idiot.
Page -- he's awful.
I cannot believe Trump is likely
to be an actual serious
candidate for president.
July 21st, 2016.
Trump is a disaster.
-I love that Graham think
it's incredible gotcha
to read a bunch of text messages
from FBI officials
calling this guy a disaster.
I mean, look at him.
[ Laughter ]
if you saw him on the street
and had no idea who he was,
you'd say, "Man,
that guy's a disaster."
[ Laughter ]
But the best part was when
Graham read a text
that had an expletive in it,
and maybe didn't realize
that he was being broadcast
live on cable news.
October 19th, 2016.
Trump is a [bleep] idiot.
[ Laughter ]
He's unable to provide
a coherent answer.
Sorry to the kids out there.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Antebellum accent ]
Why, Lindsey Beauregard Graham,
I do declare!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Man, you know, it's getting
so you can't even take your kids
out of school
on a Wednesday morning
and watch a congressional
hearing together as a family!
[ Laughter ]
Graham definitely, definitely --
[ Applause ]
Graham definitely forgot
this thing was being broadcast
live on cable news.
He probably assumed
he was just on C-SPAN,
where you can say and do
whatever you want,
because nobody is watching.
I turned it on C-SPAN
the other day
and was just a couple dogs
humping in an empty chamber.
[ Laughter ]
People don't know,
C-SPAN is like '90s Cinemax.
At 3:00 a.m.,
they hold hearings,
but they're just like
blurred out.
[ Laughter ]
But aside from dropping
an F-bomb on live TV,
Graham also decided
to briefly dabble
in what was supposed to be
the main point
of the hearing,
the Mueller report.
Now, in the actual report,
Mueller listed ten times Trump
may have obstructed justice
and he specifically turned it
over to Congress
to hold Trump accountable
for those instances.
And yet Graham brushed it off
saying Trump couldn't be guilty
of obstruction of justice,
because it didn't work.
-You have to have specific
intent to obstruct justice.
If there's no underlying crime,
pretty hard to figure out
what intent might be
if there was never a crime
to begin with.
The president never did
anything to stop Mueller
from doing his job,
so I guess the theory goes,
now, okay, he didn't collude
with the Russians
and he didn't specifically
do anything to stop Mueller,
but attempted obstruction
of justice of a crime
that never occurred.
I guess that's sort of
the new standard around here.
We'll see if that
makes any sense.
To me, it doesn't.
>> Seth: Wait, so now
your argument is that
attempted obstruction of justice
isn't a crime?
I'm no lawyer,
but last I checked,
attempting to do something
illegal is also a crime.
If you get arrested for chasing
a guy down the street
with a knife,
you can't go to court and say,
"Sure, I tried to kill him,
but he was too fast!"
[ Laughter ]
Again, the report lists
ten different times Trump
tried to interfere
in the investigation
or tried to get other people to
interfere in the investigation.
But Graham is arguing
that because Trump
never specifically told anyone
to obstruct justice,
he can't be guilty
of obstruction of justice,
which is a ridiculous argument.
But don't take it from me.
Take it from 1999 Lindsey
Graham.
-He doesn't have to say,
"go lie for me" to be a crime.
You don't have to say,
"Let's obstruct justice"
for it to be a crime.
You judge people on their
conduct, not magic phrases.
-First of all, how is it that
young Lindsey Graham
looks like more of an adult
than current Lindsey Graham?
[ Laughter ]
Now he looks like
a 12-year-old boy
who put grey dye in his hair
for a school play.
20 years from now, he's just
going to be a baby in a wig.
[ Laughter ]
Second, what do you mean
magic phrases?
What's an example
of a magic phrase?
-Trump is a [bleep] idiot.
-All right. Also, Trump did...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump did have a specific intent
to obstruct justice.
If you'd read the whole report,
you would know that.
Because in the report, Mueller's
team specifically wrote
that Trump had a motive
to end the investigation,
because he was afraid
they would find facts
about the campaign
and the president personally
that the president could have
understood to be crimes.
That's why he repeatedly
tried to interfere
in the investigation.
For example, according
to Mueller's report,
Trump told his former
White House counsel
Don McGahn to fire Mueller.
That anecdote is included
in Mueller's report,
along with some colorful
language from McGahn.
-Although McGahn recalled
receiving multiple calls
from the president
on the same day,
he was not certain
of the specific dates,
but he was confident that he had
at least two phone conversations
with the president in which
the president directed him
to call the acting
Attorney General
and have the Special Counsel
removed.
It's also the colorful reporting
from this report
where Don McGahn says
to Reince Priebus,
which is the third witness
to this incident,
"The President asked me to do
some crazy [bleep]"
-Man, cable news is feeling
salty today!
[ Laughter ]
You got Senators dropping
F-bombs,
anchors saying the words
"crazy [bleep]"
When Wolf Blitzer found out
about the Mueller letter,
he fully went off the rails.
-Alright, we got some important
breaking news --
[Bleep]
We got the -- [bleep]
has just -- [bleep]
-So we have all of this
information
from Mueller's report,
and yet instead of
taking advantage of the rare
opportunity to ask
the Attorney General
of the United States
about the possibility
that the president
of the United States
committed obstruction
of justice,
Republicans chose instead
to spend most of their time
obsessing over a person
who wasn't even in the room.
-The Inspector General found
that during
the department's investigation
of Hillary Clinton
for mishandling highly
classified information,
there was a culture
of unauthorized media contacts.
We've heard a lot about
the Steele dossier.
Mr. Steele, of course,
is a former British
intelligence officer
hired to do opposition research
by the Hillary Clinton campaign.
-Now, he's in charge of the
Clinton e-mail investigation.
-There were two investigations
here.
One was an investigation
of Donald Trump.
There was another investigation
of Hillary Clinton.
-Oh, my God, guys, let it go.
A thousand years from now
when global warming
has destroyed the planet
and hoards of zombie bandits
roam the countryside,
a gang of survivors is going
to find an abandoned room
in the Capitol with these words
scrawled in blood.
"What about Hillary's e-mails?"
[ Laughter ]
What's clear here is that
Trump's hand-picked Attorney
General
orchestrated a PR Campaign
to mislead the public
over Robert Mueller's findings
before anyone
actually got to see them.
And now we know Mueller himself
was upset about it.
If you're going to read
something,
don't leave out key words.
Read the whole thing.
You know, like Lindsey Graham.
-Trump is a [bleep] idiot.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪